Google, Adobe, Microsoft, and IBM are all
run by people who grew up in India.
The latest to join these ranks is Twitter’s
CEO Parag Agrawal who took over from Jack
Dorsey.
People originally from India make up 1% of
the total U.S. population yet about 6% of
Silicon Valley’s workforce.
So, why are there so many tech CEOS who hail
from India?
When Satya Nadella took over as CEO of Microsoft
in 2014, the company was in bad shape.
Bill Gates was reportedly an angry and difficult
boss.
His successor, Steve Ballmer, apparently wasn’t
any better.
Microsoft was also a dinosaur.
It had failed to innovate.
For example, it lost the smartphone battle
to Apple.
Along comes Nadella, an engineer who rose
through the ranks of Microsoft to become the
CEO.
Nadella changed the culture of the company.
He made it clear anger and yelling weren’t
welcome.
He also sought to make Microsoft relevant.
We now need to make Microsoft thrive in a
mobile-first and cloud-first world.
Under his direction, Microsoft moved its software
to non-Windows devices and expanded its cloud
business Azure.
That innovative spirit of problem-solving
was bred in his native country.
India is home to nearly 1.4 billion people.
It’s the second-most populous country on
earth, after China, and is expected to overtake
China as the most populous country in a few
years.
Although India has made remarkable progress,
poverty is still a major challenge.
Nearly a quarter of the population lives below
the poverty line of $1.90 a day according
to the United Nations Development Programme.
They face corruption, poor infrastructure,
and limited opportunities.
So they learn to be resilient, adapt, and
overcome endless obstacles.
This leads them to be problem-solvers - a
key asset in any corporation.
Sundar Pichai has had to solve many problems
after taking over at the helm of Google in
2015…at a time when big tech is being scrutinized
over the power they hold.
He became the archetype of a kinder, calmer,
gentler leader in tech.
Pichai earned an engineering degree at one
of the Indian Institutes of Technology.
The IITs are kind of like the Indian equivalent
of MIT with an even lower acceptance rate
reportedly of 1% or 2%.
After Pichai graduated, his ticket to America
came in the form of a Master’s at Stanford.
Going to a top grad school in the States is
how many Indians land up in the land of opportunity.
They appear to follow this well-trodden path:
They did their undergrad at a great school
in India.
Got a Master’s in the U.S.
Where they studied STEM - science, technology,
engineering, and mathematics.
More than half of all international students
in America pursued a STEM degree in the past
academic year.
American immigration favors people with specialized
skills.
After Pichai graduated, he went on an H1B
visa to work at consulting firm McKinsey.
The H1B allows American companies to employ
foreign workers, many of whom are in IT-related
fields.
The U.S. government awarded nearly 75% of
these visas to Indians in 2020.
In comparison, China trailed far behind in
second, at 12%.
The fact that so many Indians can speak English
is a tremendous advantage in the West.
And they’re comfortable with American business
culture, possibly because it mirrors the thriving
IT industry back home in Bangalore, Chennai,
and Hyderabad.
They’re also more likely to want to work
overseas.
80% of Chinese international students return
to China after graduating, according to China’s
Ministry of Education.
Chinese entrepreneurs prefer starting their
own companies at home.
Alibaba is known as the “Amazon of China”
Tencent owns the messaging app WeChat used
by 1.2 billion people.
Huawei is one of the giants of the tech industry.
China's transition from a manufacturing hub
to a tech hotbed has largely been driven by
government policy.
In the late seventies, Chinese leader Deng
Xiaoping encouraged foreign businesses to
set up offices in China which fostered a start-up
environment.
On the other hand, India has a problem of
too much talent leaving the country for good.
It has the highest number of migrants living
abroad at 17.5 million, according to the UN.
And more Indians gave up their passports to
become naturalized American citizens in 2020
than the Chinese, continuing the trend from
past years.
However, the brain drain from India may be
starting to recede.
An increasing number of homegrown Indian startups
are becoming unicorns - meaning, the companies
are valued at $1 billion or more.
The data platform Tracxn tells
Newsthink India created 47 unicorns in 2021.
A significant jump from the 17 in 2020.
And even less in years past.
The tech ecosystem is being bolstered by powerful
investment firms such as Softbank that have
been pumping money into Indian startups.
But in order to entice more people to remain
in their native country, salaries will have
to catch up with those in the West.
The average American tech worker earns around
$98,000 a year according to the online recruiting
platform, Dice.
Tech salaries in India vary greatly, but the
jobs site Indeed pegs the median tech salary
at $20,000 US going up to as much as $33,000
which makes them some of the top earners in
their country but still, far less than what
they’d make in the States.
As salaries grow along with India’s startup
boom, this could have implications for the
number of exceptional individuals desiring
to move abroad.
The one thing that the CEOs of tech giants
have in common is their strong background
in engineering.
And if you wanted to improve your STEM skills,
my sponsor Brilliant can help you achieve
your goals.
Brilliant is a website and app that lets you
tackle math, science, and computer science
concepts in a fun and hands-on way.
You can develop your critical thinking skills
through their recently updated Logic course
that forms the basis for mathematical reasoning.
Or you can jump right in to their popular
mathematical fundamentals course to master
algebra, logic, and number theory.
There’s something for everyone.
Whether it’s the foundations of computer
science or learning about cryptocurrency.
If you’re stuck on a question or get an
incorrect answer, you can read the explanation
to see where you went wrong.
Brilliant is FREE to sign up if you head to
the custom link in my description, brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 of you to sign up with my
link will receive 20% off Brilliant's annual
premium subscription, which unlocks all of
the courses.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.